the raid on the planet i think that
that's fantastic if i were ending it i
probably would have ended it after that
scene
yeah i think the reason why they didn't
is because if you end it there it's like
you're just watching everyone get
slaughtered
nobody is signing up for that bro this
is not blue valentine no
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to
another episode of the after show today
we're going to break down dune deep
diving on the details and answering some
of the burning questions
left by the film joining me today i'm so
excited first we have robert daniels
he's a film critic and contributor to
roger ebert dot com and sharonda
williams she's the producer and host of
payer weight
for the fear is gone
only i will remain
[Music]
this is where it sits right now it's
certified fresh at 85 percent critics
consensus says the dune occasionally
struggles with its unwieldy source
material but those issues are largely
overshadowed by the scope and ambition
of this visually thrilling adaptation
i'm gonna ask you folks to just give me
your quick thoughts on things and i'm
gonna start with you sharonda um are the
grand visuals and this sort of like
ambitious scale is it hard to overcome
when you're only seeing half of the
whole story like how did you feel when
you were watching it
i mean for me i think the visuals is
what really sells the first part of the
film just watching the world that
denis has brought to the screen it looks
absolutely fantastic and for those who
love david lynch's version which is not
many but it's okay i think a lot of
people will feel as though like this is
the movie that they finally deserve that
this movie should have came out at this
time
um but we'll just leave it up to the
audiences to see if it's worth it watch
yeah and i will say this though for as
much shade and there is plenty of shade
that goes to the david lynch version
which is currently rated 47 on the
tomato meter it actually has a more than
favorable audience score at 65 which is
quite low for an audience but it's not
terrible so i would say the critics
pretty well lambasted it whereas an
audience has felt it was more mixed but
robert what about you um were you swept
away by the visuals i was swept away to
nowhere except for a sandy graveyard
[Laughter]
um i mean the visuals are fantastic the
epic scale is fantastic um denise just
he's he's incredible if you give him a
big sci-fi world but i just didn't feel
any emotional tether to any one of the
characters and
you know hopefully that changes in part
two but it didn't happen in part one
let's go ahead and get to the meat of
our discussion today but before we go
any further i want to let everyone know
huge huge spoiler warning we are going
to talk about the film in its entirety
if you have not seen dune and you want
to go into it blind please click away
now and come back to this video
afterwards but this is not light
spoilers we're gonna get deep diving
into it
[Music]
let's go ahead and start with paul how
did you feel timmy did with this
character especially knowing already
what kyle mclaughlin did with it and
this is his movie
you know dune is the ip but he is the
one that leads and carries it how do you
think he did with it
i like what timothy did for what he was
given to actually do i mean i know that
this is supposed to be his film but for
me i actually see
part one as rebecca's film because i
think she had the most impact on me from
an emotional standpoint um so i think
timothy did a really good job i think
that he looked the part of paul of
seeing the internal struggle um you felt
what was expected of him that he was
weighed down by high expectations but
unsure of his own belief that he could
actually follow through and actually
meet those expectations but um yeah it's
weird i know it's supposed to be his
film for part one but i really see it as
rebecca's film robert what about you how
did you feel about timothy in the lead
role for this one and also have you seen
the original
i have i have seen the original one i
prefer kyle's version kyle mclaughlin's
version
really yeah wow facts
i just don't i don't buy timmy
he's in this role and all i see is
ladybird
truly oh man
oh man shape i understand going with
timothy for the age reason
um and common comic guaca definitely is
too old for that role he makes it work
but
um i think he's overall
a stronger actor than timothy shalom and
yeah i still feel like timothy
chamberlain has kind of like been
repeating you know these performances
over and over and over again i just i
look outside the little women i haven't
really seen the range i need to see from
that's not like just totally angsty teen
hmm so youtube were wireless today okay
i mean seriously though robert you are a
brave man they are going to find you
talking about his character i was just
talking about his character not him not
the first time i've been fouled before
[Laughter]
there's something happening to me
there's something awakening in my mind i
can't control it
what did you see
zendaya is all over these posters on the
cover of entertainment weekly dancing
around timothy chalamet and this is
worse than brian cranston in godzilla
scam this girl is barely in this movie
i don't know how well that's going to
rest with people chandra what do you
think look let me tell you something
when i say warner brothers is going to
get all day money off of
this movie for literally 60 seconds
because it's probably 60 seconds that
she's in this film i mean she was up
front with everyone they know that she's
not you know in this film that much and
i think that this only makes everyone
more excited to watch part two because
we know she will have a bigger role but
if anyone did not doesn't know she's in
a movie for two seconds literally two
seconds i mean but robert do you really
think she's gonna have a bigger role in
the second because let's be honest she's
not really
a major character in the events of the
book from what i understand or even in
the david lynch version like how much do
you think she's gonna have to do in the
second one if we know that she didn't
have much to do in this one and i'll
also add what did you think about what
she did get to do in this one
um well i think zendaya breathing would
be a lot more than what she got in this
one i mean you know i think she's going
to have a lot more to do basically is
the longer the short of it even though
this isn't a major character she
basically
lives in
um paul's dreams you know the character
itself lives in paul's dreams um and so
we get like the furtive glances but not
not much else
um
however i you know for what for for for
what she had to do you know i was like
she knows how to stand she knows how to
look
wow zendaya has more talents than giving
good face if folks don't know that they
can watch a little show called euphoria
and i'm gonna say this just to piss
robert off or a movie called malcolm and
marie but
but
you're right she doesn't have a lot to
do in this one i want to get to
some of the folks that are around the
main characters particularly jason
if you did not feel the warrior's death
of jason momoa die i was so like come on
jason momoa is so good in this like i
really hope there is
more respect on his name you really feel
the relationship like that friendship
you know that you have that he looks at
this person like you know he is a huge
mentor in his life and i just felt like
jason he was just like the perfect
person like when i watch them on screen
i was like this is perfect casting right
here and i really hope more people talk
about how good jason was in this movie
because i feel like he would be trying
to disrespect jason like he can't do
nothing and he was trying to tell y'all
i'm doing
just give me something to do and i'm
gonna make it work yeah i mean i just
want to be clear
outside of tibby i think everyone's
fantastic at this film i think all the
performances are really well done and i
think everyone's well cast
um
but i didn't feel connected to any of
these characters um
beyond
oh that's a it's a good performance by
that person you know but i think a lot
of what i loved about this movie
had to do with the actors and had to do
with their interpersonal relationships
and their rapport with each other more
so
than the knee really bringing me into
these characters the other thing too
since we're talking about this i'll ask
you this robert is there anything and
i'm obviously you can say the visuals
but is there any scene that you found
this version
did better because i would say that the
shield scene you absolutely have to say
and it's not just because of the cgi it
is also because of the physicality of
the actors who were in the scene
yeah i mean i would say the um
oh now blanking on onwards today the
raid on the planet the downfall of of
oscar x's character and paul's family i
think that
that's fantastic you know like i'm that
was the one moment where i was leaning
forward into my in my seat and if i were
ending it i probably would have ended it
after that scene and just been
just just and it would just be in part
two with them in the desert yeah i think
the reason why they didn't is because if
you end it there it's like you're just
watching everyone get slaughtered
and there's no hope
is there a problem
yes for a movie that they're trying to
market to a bunch of people yes like
nobody is signing up for that bro this
is not blue valentine no
uh what about you sharonda what was the
scene maybe particularly for you that
you felt
really elevated this version
honestly is when paul is having his test
i really
really love what you did with that scene
they made it so much more it was it was
scarier i mean literally if you move
like you're going to die like something
bad is going to happen to you that was a
scene for me i was like they really
really got that right
and i will say rebecca's
complete petrification
in that moment knowing what that meant i
felt was really well done let's go ahead
and maybe talk about some of the below
the line folks that i think we all can
agree on
really did i think their thing i hope
robert you will put it on to
both the cinematographer and han zimmer
i just feel like
both of them should get some mvp love
for this film but i'm gonna let you tell
me what you feel
i think hans zimmer 99. 99.9 percent of
time should always be the mvp um and i
think his his score is particularly good
here
[Music]
it is there is like
more of a
middle eastern tint
and so his floor did
remind me that there are no middle
eastern actors who are playing at these
major parts
so it didn't do that it's not his fault
yeah i think the creative choice was the
right creative choice uh and the
cinematography i can't fight for
cinematography cinematography is the
compositions are vast and gorgeous um
and
um
about the same level as lynch's um
cinematography because i think with
lynch you can tell that he has a
painterly background on those um and his
version of dude
and that's greg frazier he did uh zero
dark 30. he did lion um trying to think
of something else that he did uh he's
going to do the new batman so he will
also be the cinematographer on that uh
one thing we didn't talk about was after
rebecca ferguson and timmy's characters
after paul and her escape
two of the biggest events i think of the
film happened which is the sand worm
attack
and them sort of escaping that and just
the idea that paul has sort of harnessed
the dreams and the powers and he
realizes where his place is because she
sort of reveals that to him
literally as they're like running for
their lives so sharonda how do you think
that played out to be the climax of the
film did it feel climactic to you
oh absolutely not
i mean
this is one part i will agree with
robert i felt as though they should have
ended on a different part that hasn't
happened yet so i don't want to spoil it
well i guess you guys knew it was going
to be very even smarter
i know clearly but i wanted it's to go
with rebecca's character i wanted it to
be her rebirth i felt like that
should have been the moment
that it ended and because they had this
like the knife fight which i felt was
gonna give more than what it was given
in the movie it just felt very
underwhelming i was just like
you talked all this smack
and then this is the fight
i was just like it's giving me boring
right now and i just kind of felt like
if we're just gonna watch them wander in
the desert like outside of the sand worm
which looked great and fantastic i was
just like i need somebody to find them
because i just don't care anymore and i
feel like
you built up to this big siege that
takes place
and then
you're just
roaming around in the desert it's just
is
it just i i felt like they should have
ended it with her rebirth
instead of how they ended it after the
fight
i feel like that takes too many events
from the second movie because this is
the other thing there ain't much left
there's a lot of like
in the next part
it's like there's a two-year break
before people realize that paul's alive
what what are they gonna do what is the
point like what are we gonna we're gonna
just show it's gonna be a lot of paul
becoming one of the freeman's stuff that
i don't feel is gonna be dramatic so i
think they're leaving the rebirth for
the second movie because
besides the literal finale the sort of
war
for the splice and and the sort of like
guerrilla attacks they're doing i think
they're just trying to keep some big
events um
secret i mean i don't know robert
knowing how you felt about the first one
knowing how i know you didn't like
definitely the way that it ended along
with most of the film sounds like
but do you think there's hope for the
second half to fill in those emotional
gaps
yeah i mean i think of
all my complaints about this film the
lowest complaint i have is where it
ended because for me right once the
second half comes out no one is going to
silo these two parts
you know they're going to watch these
two things as continuous so it's an
issue right now but in a couple years
when it comes out and people can watch
them back to
i i don't think we're going to be
talking about where part one ended
nearly as much um i do agree though that
you know having said that it is a is a
great ending and i i wish rhonda you
know the knife fight i thought was gonna
be like some black panther thing that
was gonna go down
[Laughter]
it's definitely not that oh yeah and so
that brings us to sort of like the next
section which we've talked about part
two like it's an inevitability and
obviously
warner brothers
is now committing to that
you get it from literally the title the
minute you sit down and you see dune it
says part one you're like what
and the last scene is literally you know
zendaya turning around to timmy saying
you know this is only just the beginning
and again
that that line did feel cheesy to me i i
will admit like the i was like girl come
on
how do you feel
this two-part movie
that's day and date
that has a very big budget how is this
gamble gonna pay off and robert i'll
start with you
i don't i don't think it's gonna pay off
i mean that's not pre-pandemic
it was a it was a long shot right people
really come out for sci-fi films denise
previous film later under 2049 that
didn't do well and that had a you know
clear like mythology around it and
legend of people who had watched the
first blade runner and it didn't pull
them into watching the second so i think
you know what this movie was going to
make money was always going to be a long
shot pre-pandemic and it's even bigger
now during the pandemic and now they're
doing day in and day out um
now
that's on the financial sense in
artistic sense it could work out you
know it could it could be that
um
part of the two parts taken together
you know create some kind of bigger love
for the ip or something that i hate
using ip but
but you know i'm you know i wonder
what the studio's end game is with this
with this film because they had to know
that it you know financially it was a
pretty pretty big risk so i'm wondering
what are they gonna do after part two
i mean i just i feel like for this movie
it's weird because it is a sci-fi film
but it's
star-studded i mean as someone in their
their tweens who saw titanic
four times in the theater just because
of leo i mean i just don't want to rule
out the timothy fans the zendaya fans
like the oscar isaac who is just having
the best year of his life
um fans but i mean i don't i don't know
i feel like it'll do well overseas but
it's just hard cause i'm really shocked
that warner brothers has even kept this
model of still releasing on hbo max and
in theater same day um
i i don't know that it makes it so
unpredictable now as far as whether or
not people are going to actually go to a
theater and especially when they realize
what the run time is as well for the
film i think that's a huge factor that
comes into play for it
we talked to jason blum in a twitter
spaces not too long ago for a different
project but he talked a little bit about
halloween kills and that decision for it
to go to peacock and he said it was
their decision
and that decision seemed to have worked
out and it was day and date
the weekend the halloween kills came out
peacock was the number one downloaded
app in the app store and on google play
so
it got people to get on the service
which is what they wanted and it still
did 50 million dollars at the box office
so and i think it was because they knew
that they would have
enough people committed to seeing the
scary movie in the theater
and they also knew that enough people
would want to sit at home
and watch it at home but they still
would like get on the peacock train to
do it this one does it have that does it
it's does it make it an event because
people are calling it star wars meets
lord of the rings but i don't know if we
feel the event of that do you sharonda
i think it's the timing i mean when you
say halloween kills it came out in
october people are wanting to see scary
movies there's not a ton of scary like
new scary movies that are coming out
that are big blockbusters when i think
of a movie like doom
i i think
christmas release date i mean we're
releasing this in october
when i just think going to see a sci-fi
film i mean everyone's on the mind of i
want to watch something with horror and
there's not a ton of action in this so
you i don't know if you can necessarily
say that this film has action to lure
those types of audiences
i don't know i found i find the timing
of the release
it's a it's a little weird to me
a little suspect i guess uh robert what
about you i mean do you feel
regardless of how you feel about the
film do you feel it's event ties i mean
i mean point-blank period do you think
this is going to make money
um you know it's hard to compare to
a horror film because it feels like
you know since the pandemic horror films
have felt more bulletproof at the box
office people have been more willing to
go and you know especially blue because
they they're usually
they don't have much high budgets you
know so it's usually pretty easy to
clear that budget um
with dude it's interesting as you say
that it's been it's being sold as star
wars and northern rings and i feel like
those i don't know if that's the best
selling point for this film because when
i think of like star wars and lord of
the rings i think these really big
emotional sweeping ethics and dune isn't
particularly emotional there are
emotional scenes but it is it is a very
like you know i want to say cold and dis
it's cerebral palsy it's more of a
cerebral it's a cerebral one no i would
agree with you on that there's a lot of
emotions behind it but it's cerebral in
the sense of it hits you in and it's
it's think it hits you with how you
think about these characters
yeah and so when i think about like you
know star wars and lord of the rings and
someone was like oh this is like that
i'm going in with completely different
expectations than what this film is
actually giving so i i think you know
some of the
you know
the way the conversation is being set i
think is even for me who doesn't who
doesn't really like this one is doing a
disservice to the movie
another big question
blade runner 2049 definitely didn't like
clean up as far as
box office but it was nominated very
heavily below the line and it got roger
deakins his first oscar
uh robert i'll start with you how do you
think it's gonna fare awards wise um
it's gonna do very well and below the
line votes much much like a blade runner
did um i think
the technical components of this totally
una unimpeachable
whether it breaks into acting or best
picture those have always been really
difficult for sci-fi films with the
academy awards um so i i doubt that
that's gonna happen but i do think that
it's gonna get some recognition from the
academy
yeah i think his only chances will
honestly be technical i mean there's a
lot of like feel good just make the
oscar voter voters tingle type of movies
coming out on this award season i mean
it's the truth but i just think for me
technical will probably be his best bet
for the film
last question and i guess this is the
one that we hope we don't have to answer
but if
this movie only makes like 25 million
dollars this weekend after halloween
kills made 50 and we don't see a huge
hbo max spike and it's pirated across
the internet
all very likely possibilities
what's denny's next move
um i still think he's gonna be making
number two and that's
because you know
warner brothers took a big hit with the
hbo max decision in terms of with
creatives and if they were to plug on
part two i don't think it's feasible for
them i think they have to stand behind
behind their director and just go full
steam ahead but there's a financial
imperative i don't disagree with you
i don't think anybody was more salty
than probably the folks of warner
brothers when christopher nolan
announced that he's doing oppenheimer at
universal because that was like
huge he made nothing but
warner brothers films for the past 15
years and you can definitely put a
direct line
in his choice to do that with how he
felt about the hbo max and i'm not
making any determinations
the quotes are out there christopher
nolan has made it very clear how he felt
about that decision and even denny said
how he felt about that decision he said
he felt like you know putting a speed
boat in a bathtub so i do think that
perhaps there is a little creative pr to
do but there's still a financial
imperative
i think it's possible that we could only
get one dude i'm not saying that i want
or think that will happen but i think
it's more than possible if
the film doesn't perform the way they
want sharon what about you
we're getting a part two
you think so
yeah we're getting a part two i mean at
that point
i i say take the gamble you know right
now the knee can say we were in the
middle of a pandemic
he can say that the same you know the
hbo max and theater same day release was
a factor of it i just don't see there's
there's too many things pointing towards
why it failed there's too many different
ways that they can blame why this movie
bombed um that they would have to give
them a part two and take also take the
gamble that you know it's gonna take
what two years to film it so it'll be
two or three years before we actually
get to see it that you know as an
economy we will be back we'll be back to
normal so and we'll be back to the point
where everyone wants to watch movies and
theaters so we gonna get that part too
it'll be interesting to see when we get
this part two remember uh warner
brothers will have a different daddy
it'll be under discovery plus it will
not be under a t so we will see how that
goes as well that is another factor into
that decision making i want to thank
both of you seriously for coming on it
was really fun to chat with you uh
sharonda
let folks know where they can find you
you can find me at pear weights on all
social media platforms but all of my
reviews and interviews are on youtube
so hope to see you there people can find
me
on twitter at a12 film reviews
specifically the timmy fans thank you
they're going to find out anyways miles
give the whole address um
but
you can also read me at rodripa.com the
playlist polygon
um new york times at lake times and a
few other places all right that's it for
us this time on the after show i want to
thank everyone all of you for watching
and you can check us out next time on
our very next episode see y'all then bye
[Music]
[Music]
you